When we look at the human body we see a series of sticks because that's all I can draw.
But that's not really what we see. We see a human body.
If we take a magnifying glass to a part of this and really zoom in on this region what do we see?
We see cells. In fact, we see something like 10¹³ cells.
That's a 1 followed by 13 zeros. That's a massive number.
Well let's not stop there. Let's zoom in on a cell. That's a magnifying glass by the way.
If we zoom in on the cell, we see that it's made up of molecules
and those molecules are made up of atoms.
And here I've drawn a single atom. This atom has three interesting parts.
Here in the center we have the nucleus. The red and the blue dots.
I'm using the red dot to represent the proton, and the proton has a charge of +1.6x10⁻¹⁹C.
Also in the nucleus we have the neutrons which have a charge of 0 so we call them neutral.
And orbiting around outside the nucleus we have electrons.
And electrons have a charge of -1.6x10⁻¹⁹C.
Same as the proton but negative. Each of these cells—
Each of the 10¹³ cells in the human body has about 10¹⁵ protons,
10¹⁵ neutrons, and 10¹⁵ electrons.
So my question is, using all of these data you have here of these numbers,
I want you to tell me what is the net or total charge and remember Q is charge
on the human body. Enter your answer here in Coulombs.